cela fait huit semaines qu'ils occupent
le grand théâtre de tours intermittents
du spectacle et travailleurs précaires
ont décidé d'employer les grands moyens
pour se faire entendre et faire plier le
gouvernement pour qu'il abandonne la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
mais aujourd'hui la direction de
l'établissement aimerait se réapproprier
les murs pour pouvoir rouvrir le 19 mai
prochain
les négociations sont en cours sur place
samuel collants
les seins denses en soutien des autres
une quarantaine d'occupants les
dernières en place à l'intérieur du
grand théâtre
s'ils sortent ils ne rentreront pas la
grille principale est désormais fermée à
clé la direction et la mairie ne les met
pas dehors
mais leur propose de se déplacer dans
une salle à l'arrière du bâtiment
on n'a plus du tout de visibilité si on
part dans cette petite salle qui est
derrière le grand théâtre et donc on se
on aurait aimé pouvoir discuter avec la
direction mais monsieur le directeur est
parti à quitter là avec quelques
employés hier à quitter la nôtre notre
réunion de négociation une négociation
sur les modalités d'occupation la salle
des coeurs ne leur serait ouverte qu'en
journée de 9h à 18h et puis l'affichage
devrait être enlevé du front du grand
théâtre
car la direction et les salariés de
l'opéra ont une priorité désormais
préparer la réouverture
il n'y a pas d'affrontement c'est juste
qu'on essaie de trouver une solution qui
est pas idéal pour nous qui n'est pas
idéal pour eux mais c'est la
cohabitation et on nous demande de
rester dans leur établissement
après huit semaines de présence ce qu'on
fait volontiers mais c'est évidemment ça
change la configuration quoi les
occupants devraient a priori quitté les
lieux dans la soirée
l'ouverture des salles de spectacle est
prévu le 19 mai et le prochain spectacle
à l'opéra le 11 juin prochain